[Music]
yeah what's the funniest deleted tweet
part two
if men didn't cheat some of you guys
wouldn't be born
a lot of people wouldn't be born
wow facts there's a tweet and a quote
tweet fellas what's the biggest red flag
you ignored just to beat reply hiv oh
that's impossible that's impossible
that's impossible
that's an hiv
wow
is everything you can bang knowing she's
got hiv and you just risk it
no wings you like i'm strapping up the
one eye oh you do what you want
probably there's probably like
it's probably a lot of girls
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm thinking about i'm just thinking
about instagram as we speak
there's bear things on bangladesh
it's actually disgusting
if anybody will tell me more
for so yeah when she's there like pack
me harder
so please please please
like you feel that real wet wet
you think well i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die so i'm gonna eventually go for it
anyway
so let me just bang this out literally
let me bang this out wow
[ __ ] that's disgusting
right it's been six days since my sneaky
link and my [ __ ] still stinks
yuck [ __ ]
she's vexed boy
put a little
put a little pepper in your pillowcase
so when you put her face in it she
sneezes and that [ __ ] gonna grip you
like a gorilla fist
what's wrong with people
what is wrong with people like a gorilla
[ __ ] sake you [ __ ] if you wear a
seatbelt real [ __ ] fly out the
windshield and die
reply that's how my brother died replied
he's a real [ __ ]
[ __ ] sake man
my baby mama said i got to unfollow you
reply leave her and the baby
[Laughter]
wow
do you guys think sucking dick was a
thing in jesus time are one million
percent
one million percent them greek roman
times
them greek brothers were sucking
they were sucking they were on stuff
they were they were on stuff
you got your body done by begging [ __ ]
to buy you food eat your own ass
oh my j's cousin told me she was
pregnant as an april fool's joke i was
so scared
what
what
that's the third incest tweet today um
that's the third incest tweet today
these lot are
pussy's scary as [ __ ]
what if i put it in and it won't let go
quote sweet
now that we're all grown up is the [ __ ]
actually real
[Laughter]
is the [ __ ] actually real oh god that's
jokes
oh
god
homophobia is hilarious bro because why
are you scared of another man giving you
top laughing my ass off like bro that's
the dream
[Laughter]
oh my god that's so funny every time
every time john marant turns on the
turbo on the fast break i curl my toes
to the point of cramps
oh
he's a unit
he's a unit his athleticism doesn't make
sense
he just jumps damn it doesn't make sense
selling [ __ ] for emergencies why you
guys be selling your [ __ ] for seafood
boil
[Laughter]
is for emergencies
oh my god oh
[ __ ] sweating [ __ ]
i got a deal with first i got to deal
with my first sexual harassment in the
workplace as a supervisor he told her
he told a co-worker her titties were
jiggling at 55 jiggles per minute
[ __ ] man
yo
bro people
people don't i swear down especially
with this whole like boris but lava that
happened yeah but this man ain't taking
sexual assault seriously
it's not it's it's funny that it's not
[ __ ] funny bro the way boris was like
bro i didn't even did you did you read
the whole thing so he's got nowhere
he's going yeah um well to be here by
the time this this is really easy
yeah um
a man said when the whole thing was
coming out and everyone was resigning
because of homeboy him giving the
homeboy the job yeah and mike came out
was like bro i didn't even know it was a
ting i didn't even know it was a take
and then literally like half an hour
later
yeah
okay i knew it was a thing
i need stuff oh yeah i knew i knew it
was a teamwork i didn't know i didn't
know it was deep like yeah yeah he's not
getting the job now
[ __ ] it up that guy's scum oh bro
all right couple more
give a man a wife feed him for a day
teach him how to get hoes feed him for
life
fam have you ever wiped and wiped and
wiped and the toilet paper wasn't wasn't
white so you just gave up
wow
i've been close i've never given up i've
been very close never given up i've
never given up and i said i'm never back
i've never backed down from from a
shitty ass crap
but
it's been time i've wiped a white into
this red raw
and there's still dude on there
the only time i've stopped doing it is
if i knew i'm good after i'm taking a
[ __ ] i'm just jumping in a chair you've
got no choice yeah yeah i'm gonna have
to just bend over in the shower
[Laughter]
and scrub this puppy clean because it's
just not making sense stop making
friends
i've been wiping
it's like you had a lava sense diarrhea
and your ass just said now
halfway midstream your archer said nah
because fab it's not making sense
oh that was funny
[Music]